mon gouvernement annonce que le québec
reprend ses droits sur le pétrole de
l'île d'anticosti en nous une annonce
importante aujourd'hui faite par pauline
marois montréal québec dit oui à
l'exploration pétrolière sur l'île
d'anticosti et c'est pour bientôt à
compter de l'été prochain maxime
bertrand à une annonce en grande pompe
il y avait beaucoup de mines etc elle
était accompagnée donc par aussi des
groupes intéressés par les entreprises
et les québec va investir 100 millions
en fait plus de 100 millions 115
millions de dollars plus précisément
patrice alors du gouvernement du québec
a signé des ententes même créé des
coentreprises
d'abord avec pétrolia comme edward with
all c et maurel et prom est conclu une
entente de principe celle là avec junex
le but est bien procéder à l'exploration
pétrolière sur l'île d'anticosti
parce qu'on veut savoir s'il ya ou non
du pétrole sur l'île d'anticosti et pour
vérifier et bien il faut explorer a dit
le gouvernement marois alors le ces
ententes ont été signées par le
gouvernement du québec vont lui
permettre de contrôler 50% des permis
sur l'île et d'obtenir 60 % des
bénéfices de l'exploitation du pétrole
si pétrole il ya le gouvernement marois
fait déjà miroiter des retombées de 45
milliards de dollars sur 30 ans alors
selon la première ministre bien cette
initiative vise à permettre à la
province de reprendre ses droits sur
cette ressource écoutons là
mon gouvernement annonce que le québec
reprend ses droits sur le pétrole de
l'île d'anticosti
en osant et en innovant encore une fois
des ressources naturelles qui nous
appartiennent une plus grande
indépendance énergétique
ça signifie plus de prospérité pour le
québec tous les québécois en seront plus
riches collectivement et
individuellement
et maxime on a voulu rassurer ceux qui
craignent l'exploitation pétrolière
justement oui la ministre des ressources
naturelles martin ouellette a dit que la
démarche allait être structuré et
rigoureuse et qu'elle allait tenir
compte des impacts environnementaux
ecoutons-la
avec le modèle d'affaires de la
coentreprise que nous proposons
aujourd'hui nous nous assurons que le
gouvernement soit partie prenante de
l'ensemble des opérations et des
bénéfices avec des bénéfices pouvant
atteindre 45 milliards de dollars pour
le gouvernement il y a un intérêt
économique certain
alors l'exploration devrait commencer
cet été l'été 2014 et aux journalistes
lui ont demandé si on était en fait en
campagne électorale provinciale et bien
pauline marois a répondu et je cite ce
n'est pas une annonce électorale bon ben
c'est très bien alors qu'on ya toujours
des rumeurs de ce budget la semaine
prochaine suivi voilà quelques jours
ensuite par le lancement d'une campagne
électorale que les lieux soient début
avril soit toute fin mars merci maxime
mais je vous en prie pas triste au
revoir au revoir